whiny liberals and lazy teachers always
cry for more and more funding for
education it's never enough
never never enough lucky for us one
brave state refuses to be held hostages
by such demands we said our citizen
journalist Laura gray to dig a little
deeper the Oklahoma school system is
going broke Oklahoma is in the midst of
an educational crisis of historic
proportions school districts look to
save cash ninety seven have gone to a
four-day week this year the state cut 34
million dollars in education funding
critics say that's in part due to years
of giving tax breaks to oil companies
the shame stream media likes to blame
tax breaks to oil companies but we've
seen this before and we all know who's
the real enemy it's time to change the
way teachers are evaluated no more
passes they're being paid very well and
it's a part time job yes maybe it's the
teachers who drain education funds in
the form of a weekly handout they call a
paycheck
anyone who is literally looking for
handouts Teresa Danks a teacher on the
side of the road panhandling electing
money to buy school supplies for her
class
I'm going to confront this hobo teacher
I made a sign to try to send a message
to the public about the situation that
Oklahoma schools are in what's the
situation in this state we just had
another 10 million dollar budget cut to
our public schools and we were already
the bottom of the barrel how much is
your salary I make a little under
$35,000 a year depending on the year
I've spent two three thousand dollars
out of my own pocket and there's
teachers across America doing the same
thing can I just ask if you wanted to
have money for school supplies why did
you take such a low paying job gotcha
a woman who works with kids 60 hours a
week Theresa insists that underfunding
public schools led to a supply shortage
I'm gonna fact-check her against the
most reliable source I know children do
you have enough school supplies you know
I'm getting a lot of different messages
from the great yes you do see kids don't
lie they have enough supplies and guess
what Oklahoma teachers do - turns out
someone's been giving them free stuff we
received a box that we can use in the
classroom I'm just amazed that we get
something that's free that is this great
but who is this selfless group of people
called the oerb i sat down with state
representative Micky Dolenz to find out
Oklahoma energy resources Ward it's a
group that is funded by the oil and gas
industry great Big Oil is putting
themselves in kids of classrooms nothing
wrong with that Oh er B's educational
material is very one-sided one thing you
will not find in the oerb curriculum is
any perspectives on climate change and
it's indoctrinating kids - you only see
one side of the story when it comes to
Oklahoma's
energy options looks like Oh er B
delivers school supplies and in return
they're simply asking teachers to use
their curriculum to teach things like
the importance of fracking oil refining
how to look fly petroleum gas you know
kids stuff
company were to go into your school and
fund a curriculum that curriculum would
be highly likely to favor their industry
why couldn't this solve your budget
problem if you just had more
corporations come into schools like you
could have big soda sponsor free lunches
you could have big pharma sponsor you
know nap time maybe have a ritalin
sponsor pop quiz you are teaching this
curriculum to third graders and that has
no place in a third grade classroom and
in any elementary classroom too bad
Mickey Oh Arabi curriculum is in 95% of
Oklahoma school districts they even make
these adorable children's books called
petrol pits big bad dream in it pet
repeat learns what a world would be like
with no petroleum byproducts no
toothbrush no soccer balls no soft-serve
ice cream
wait is that real well whatever it is
it's a total goddamn nightmare and who
reads this to kids
Oklahoma's lawmakers i wouldn't condone
reading petrol pee to third graders what
does have a place in a third grade
classroom and zhan materials hands-on
training really really do so many hands
sure Big Oil is getting millions of
dollars in tax breaks and leaving
climate change out of their super cool
experiments but you know what they're
not getting thank you come on sorry
thank you cards I need to use Oklahoma's
most precious resource no not the kids
oil to thank Oklahoma's future
the oil thank we are be for all they are
doing in your schools and what better
messenger than their very own mascot
Petro Pete they're gonna love it
hi how are you nice to meet you I have
some thank you cards for the oerb okay
we're gonna need permission for the
camera they were too busy probably
shaping the minds of our youth so I'm
heading to oils real home the capital
the Oklahoma State government gave 216
million dollars in tax breaks to big oil
while cutting school a funding by 214
million but that's a lot of numbers if
you really want to see where their heart
lies all you have to do is look up
Phillips Petroleum Halliburton Conoco
they literally sponsored the building
I'm looking for any senators that voted
against raising the education budget and
Crowell okay they are all too modest to
take credit anybody in this hallway vote
not to raise education I've got some
thank-you cards but everyone should know
who is responsible
[Music]
[Applause]